watching a movie with friends and loved
ones can enrich the experience for
everyone but as with all things there
are exceptions trust us you won't want
someone sitting next to you while any of
these movies are on her is a film about
a lonely dude who buys a sophisticated
operating system that contains a
charming artificial intelligence and
then promptly falls in love with her
it's quite literally about a man who
falls in love with the screen in that
way there's something absolutely perfect
about watching it by yourself
particularly if you're feeling a tad
lonely just for the sheer satirical
value of it all beyond that though
there's something more to her that begs
to be considered in a solitary quiet way
some people see the film as more of a
comedy mocking our relationship to
technology others meanwhile see it is a
very sincere study of our relationship
to tech and to each other either way
it's a fascinating film full of
questions you'd rather not have a friend
asking aloud in your ear while you watch
Alex Garland's gorgeous yet disturbing
sci-fi masterpiece was one of the most
under seen but fascinating films of 2018
and now that it's available to watch at
home you're in a prime position to watch
it in the dark by yourself absorbing
every little detail of the shimmer in
the weird way it seeps into the brains
of the film's characters annihilation is
a film rich in visual and thematic
textures
it's a treatise on trauma and guilt an
exploration of what it means to be an
individual and a glimpse and what
happens when we finally get the
transformation we so desperately seek
it's also a film that leaves the answers
to the questions it Ponder's somewhat
ambiguous and while it can be fun to
discuss theories with people the moment
the movie is over annihilation is a
story that rewards silent contemplation
it's a film that begs you not only to
watch it intently but to sit with it in
silence for a while after the credits
have rolled with the right audience the
original Twin Peaks series can be a
blast to watch in a group it's quirky
it's funny it's scary without being
overwhelming and it's full of fun little
character details and quotes you can all
talk about later I turn the town of Twin
Peaks
five miles south of the Canadian border
12 miles west of the state line ever
seen so many tree in Atlanta like fire
walk with me the prequel film that
followed the original shows cancellation
is a different beast
directed by co-creator David Lynch
without his twin peaks' creative partner
mark frost fire walk with me abandons
many of the more comedic and
light-hearted elements of the series in
favor of the Bleak brutal absolutely
nightmarish story of the last week of
Laura Palmer's life it's often a hard
film to watch and it expands to piques
mythology in ways that are often hard to
grasp upon first viewing even with that
feature-length collection of deleted
scenes to expand the series lower
watching it with a raucous crowd of Twin
Peaks fans might not work so instead
watch it quietly and absorb the mini
mysteries of a place both wonderful and
strange even at theirs Aeneas the films
of the Coen brothers are all marked by
the duo's detail-oriented and deeply
intellectual signature style that makes
nearly all of them challenging in some
way but Barton think might be their most
cerebral effort ever this a real story
of a gifted playwright who heads out to
Hollywood in an attempt to bring a
degree of seriousness and meaning to
motion pictures the film is an
existential examination of creative self
seriousness which the film itself both
embraces and pokes fun at strange as it
may seem Charlie I I guess I write about
people like you the average working
stiff the common man well ain't that a
kick in the head
the film's themes dialogue and visual
symbolism almere the process of Fink's
own confidence and intellectual prowess
going up in flames and what a glorious
fire it is watching the film alone both
enhances the sense of isolation you
share with Fink as a viewer and
underlines the cerebral loneliness at
play like the films of the Coen brothers
the films of Paul Thomas Anderson are
often overwhelmingly cerebral rich with
a meaning that isn't always obvious but
is always compelling enough to make a
careful viewer lean forward and take
notice
the master perhaps more than any of his
other work deliberately grabs it viewers
attention with a tale about a
charismatic leader played by the late
Philip Seymour Hoffman and the curious
converts who joins his cause you
shouldn't work in your condition
or your aberrated or not know what that
means no comparisons to l ron Hubbard
and Scientology are obvious on the
surface but whatever the master is
searching for in its own tense
fascinating way runs much deeper than a
thinly veiled allegory for a real-life
belief system in Anderson's hands the
film becomes a meditation on manhood
faith self destruction longing fear and
raw human endurance
these are heavy things in a heavy movie
and they're really worth sitting with
alone particularly if the people you
typically share your couch with are the
type to ask too many questions the film
itself isn't willing to answer if we
meet again in the next life you will be
my sworn enemy
and I will show you no mercy
[Music]